dive into the world of vegetable farming
a realm where your precious produce is
perishable the key to success
understanding your markets to ensure
your good sell at a compelling margin
ready for a top secret first initiate
your planting when the market is
brimming with excess Farm
produce counterintuitive isn't it but
stick with me next take a step back
during times of scarcity why you ask
well most will be planting during this
period resulting in an overwhelming flow
blood of
produce causing a surplus once again but
remember this strategy has its
limitations some crops are season
specific so you'll need to consider the
suitability of your chosen crops for
this strategy and there you have it the
secret to thriving in the vegetable
farming business until next time stay
curious subscribe